the general availability of IBM aiops
insights new IBM turbonomic tools and
the G2 summer reports all on this
episode of IBM Tech now
what's up y'all my name is Ian and I am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements about
IBM technology
as modern I.T environments grow in
complexity it Ops teams need more and
more tools to manage them
this means it's becoming increasingly
challenging to maintain a complete view
of your end-to-end it environment and
effectively manage events and incidents
that's why IBM is thrilled to announce
the general availability of IBM AI Ops
insights a platform that provides a
comprehensive view of your Managed IT
environment through a single pane of
glass
AI Ops insights enables you to more
quickly detect identify and collaborate
on incidents by aggregating information
from a cross-domain event metric and
topology ingestion
simply put this means that incident
resolution becomes more streamlined
the solution automatically triages
incidents groups alerts isolates faults
and routes incidents to the appropriate
teams making the entire resolution
process faster and more efficient
to learn more about the capabilities of
IBM AI Ops insights check out the link
in the description of this video
next up IBM turbonomic is excited to
launch the next phase in our commitment
to provide automation tools that help
you understand the energy use and carbon
emissions of your data centers
turbonomics Now tracks the energy
consumption and carbon footprint of
on-prem hosts and virtual machines to
help you put your sustainability goals
into action
with the latest release you get energy
and carbon emission reports to help your
it teams identify and reduce energy
consumption and Associated CO2 emissions
you can monitor the energy consumption
and carbon footprint of your it
infrastructure and view the relevant
data in charts including an energy
consumption chart that collects energy
related data from hosts and VMS at 10
minute intervals and a carbon footprint
chart that allows you to view carbon
dioxide equivalent emissions for any
given virtual machine
there are many more dashboards and tools
available in the latest release of IBM
turbonomic so hit the link below to
learn more
to wrap things up today the G2 summer
reports were recently released and IBM
has been named a leader IBM offerings
were featured in more than 1300 unique
G2 reports earning a top three product
placement in over 400 reports across
various categories
the G2 summer reports showcase vendors
that excel in three key areas ease of
implementation ease of use and
relationship ratings
IBM products and solutions ranked number
one in 135 unique reports and ranked in
the top three in 279 unique reports
these awards are a demonstration of
IBM's unrelenting Focus to drive value
for clients and continuously improve in
the uncertainty of today's economic
climate to learn more hit the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM Tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video
and again please don't forget to
subscribe to our channel to stay up to
date on what's going on in Tech now